he should have let me bump off harvey
dent we'd all have been better off
wouldn't we have yeah you can't defend
your attempted murder by saying that
everyone would be better off if you
actually completed the murder itself
[Music]
today we're going to take a deep dive
into my childhood with one of my
favorite shows of all time batman the
animated series you know as a kid i used
to watch it with my father i'm a real
lawyer so let's react to batman the
animated series the trial episode
[Music]
all right trail no i'm sorry trial the
trial episode all right pauldini and
bruce w tim we'll see if you can write a
good courtroom episode
pamela lillian eisley district attorney
van dorn has asked that the maximum
sense of life imprisonment be imposed
upon you maximum sentence for what in
batman the animated series
i don't think anyone ever actually dies
uh and i don't think poison i think this
is poison ivy right so call me bro
what is she getting the maximum sentence
of life in prison for i mean i guess
maybe attempted murder she did try and
kill a lot of people all right all right
so
if she was really i don't know what the
particular circumstances are here but
the district attorney has asked for the
maximum sentence i don't know that that
fits with the sentencing guidelines even
though this is new york state not
actually the federal system but uh i'll
allow it i'll allow it however as your
apprehension came at the hands of the
batman and not a recognized agent of the
law this court has no choice okay all
right uh a couple of big problems here
first of all we've talked a lot on this
channel about how batman is a vigilante
the things he's doing are illegal
subjects him to all kinds of actual
criminal penalties putting that aside
when batman apprehends a
wrongdoer who has also done something
wrong that doesn't mean that they don't
go to jail they can be sentenced to jail
just like anyone else the fact that a
vigilante has captured them i don't
think has any actual repercussions in
the actual police and judicial system
itself this court has no choice but to
return you to arkham asylum where it is
hoped you will complete your
rehabilitation okay but what does that
have to do with anything so if they're
captured by batman going to arkham
asylum is effectively the result of
being found guilty of a crime now arkham
asylum my recollection is that it's a
mental institution and if you're found
not guilty by reason of insanity which
you know a lot of these i guess super
villains are you could be sent to some
sort of facility like that but
you know it's for an indefinite amount
of time but
what the judge is saying is a
non-sequitur here he's saying we can't
do anything with you because you were
captured by batman but also i'm going to
send you to this mental institution
because you're not guilty by mental
insanity i don't know what's going on
here so far this doesn't check out
[Music]
you know for a mental institute this
looks a lot like a prison i'm i think
there's some blurring some lines here
between a a mental institution and just
a flat out
super max prison here well cheer up
where it is we're gonna throw a little
party and all jervis here has the
invitations i mean i suppose it does
make sense that the mad hatter does
reside in arkham asylum more so than
anyone else i have no reason to believe
why all of those other criminals should
be in arkham asylum instead of you know
an actual
prison not only does batman create these
so-called super criminals he takes it
upon himself to be their judge and jury
with no regard for the legal system well
that's not true
batman literally leaves the prisoners on
the doorstep of the police so that the
police can arrest the prisoners and then
theoretically they'll be tried by the
district attorney who you know once was
harvey dent and now is is miss van dorn
uh yeah i don't think i agree with that
i think that's unnecessarily uh cynical
it sounds like you want to put batman on
trial believe me i'd like nothing better
well yeah so look batman deserves to be
on trial for a whole host of reasons
that are apart from the fact that he's
judge jury and executioner he's not
really any of those things uh he is a
vigilante and
you know should be put on trial but
that's sort of neither here nor there as
gotham's new district attorney i can't
allow your pet not to run loose in my
city that's fair i mean it
janet it's a war zone out there and
batman is our best weapon and i say he's
a drug the city keeps taking to avoid
facing reality speak of the devil the
east side skulls are ready to declare
war on the other gangs old news my
department's already planning a sting to
catch the skull's leader don't bother
very cute mister but so i mean the issue
with
gang land violence is not that you don't
know who the gang members are and just
you can go arrest them is that you have
to actually have enough evidence that
they have done the things that they were
accused of and so here batman hasn't
done
really much good because he's just
simply captured someone that i'm sure
the district attorney and the police
already knew was a member of this gang
system so
uh yeah batman they're not doing his
best here you want to support law in
order you take off that mask and put on
a uniform yeah i mean that's that's fair
next time i see him it'll be a whole
different story um
will it though
hello bruce yeah janet of course so glad
we're able to meet on such short notice
still even you have to admit batman's
come through now and then but look at
the lunatic fringe he's created the
joker two-face poison ivy and the rest
batman's responsible for every one of
them
is he so okay is that where this this
episode is going that batman is actually
responsible for
creating the super villains that he is
policing as well
i mean
interesting we'll we'll see where that
goes i mean that might get into issues
of proximate cause versus actual cause
uh but that's that's kind of a straw man
so it'll be interesting to see what she
does with that i'm sorry bruce i won't
be a minute
take your time
is is that a uh
i hate to see you go but i love watching
you leave joke did they did they
shoehorn that into a kid's
cartoon here hmm i wonder if they're
being a little cheeky there no pun
intended
let me out do you hear me whoever you
are let me out this second
again this really really looks like a
prison here rather than any kind of
institute that would actually be for
psychological or psychiatric purposes we
got some legal business to sell first
what do you mean
i'm
you know what i like the idea i like the
setup of this episode making the uh
single-minded district attorney who
actually doesn't like batman to be
forced to defend him uh though it's
interesting that when these
supervillains finally have the upper
hand they have batman
incapacitated uh they decide to do this
legal nonsense instead of you know
actually unmasking him and you know
killing him yeah not a great plan from
their perspective but a great conceit
for an episode i love it as far as i'm
concerned you belong in here with them
ah
whatever
you've got to go through with it it's
their game and their rules you've said
it yourself lady batman made every one
of us
so we're facing him before the bar to
face our justice okay amusing idea what
kidnapping you to be batman's attorney
okay so uh legally speaking putting
aside the fact that this trial is
completely uh rigged and impossible this
would be a very very easy case for this
lawyer to win because just because
someone is an actual cause doesn't mean
that they are the proximate cause the
legal cause of something happening and
when you're talking about a bunch of
super villains who are
i i i use this term loosely in control
of their faculties they're committing a
bunch of intentional torts and a bunch
of intentional crimes so that batman
though he might have you know placed a
domino or flipped domino over in this
long string of dominoes that led to the
creation of these supervillains he's not
actually responsible for
the things that they have done so
theoretically this lawyer should have a
pretty easy time likewise our fear
an impartial jury
hang him shade him hit him with a rock
okay so i probably don't need to tell
you that this jury is completely
constitutionally in firm first of all
you don't have 12 people which is not a
requirement in all states but generally
you do have 12
this is not an impartial selection of
people in this area batman is not being
tried by a selection of his peers under
the sixth amendment a jury has to be a
representative cross sample of the
people in that geographical location and
not only is this petty jury the i think
six supervillains who are there not
representative of the community at large
there was no jury panel there was no
veneer
through which you could choose the
members of the jury it has to be
impartial and it doesn't mean that they
can't know anything about the accused
but it does mean that they have to be
able to put what they know aside and
here
they are
material witnesses they are absolutely
not impartial against batman and so yeah
believe it or not a jury made up of
exclusively of super villains does not
pass constitutional muster judge joker
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so uh joker as the the judge that
doesn't pass constitutional muster
either
he needs to be bounced for uh
for uh not being uh capable of presiding
over this trial i was promised a chance
to defend my client oh very well
like it'll make a difference mr
prosecutor make your opening statement
yeah so in california you have a
procedure through which you ask the
judge to no longer preside over your
trial and sometimes you can just do it
automatically it's called 170.6 in the
judge after that particular section of
the california code you definitely want
to make a 176.6 motion in this
particular case we're all freaks and
monsters
and who made us this way
batman
yeah
yeah not so much
so in law school you spend a huge amount
of time talking about the difference
between actual cause and proximate cause
and uh in fact uh
often you're dealing with really dry
cases there is one particular case in
law school that i think is actually
really interesting that talks about this
very distinction it's called the paul's
graph case and it involves a guy who
brings some fireworks onto a train the
box of fireworks explodes and it tips
over this giant scale onto this poor
woman named palsgraf and so the main
question in that case is not whether the
guy who brought the fireworks is he
responsible but the question is is the
railroad at any point responsible and i
actually did an entire video called
what's in the box that talks about this
very case it's all animated which is
fitting because this is batman the
animated series so if you are curious
about how that case turned out and the
difference between actual and proximate
cause you can check out that video yo
hot understand yeah right out of the
jury into the witness box that is uh
counselor you brainwashed and kidnapped
a woman who rejected you that man forced
me to do it he was going to take her
away from me i had no choice yeah you
could have respected her wishes and left
her alone i got killed at first
i'd like that last thing
from the record please
record is someone supposed to be writing
this down
yeah well someone is supposed to be
writing it down so i actually really
like that cross-examination well
uh actually so was there there was no
direct examination yeah so i guess we'll
call that cross-examination that really
actually highlights the difference
between actual cause and proximate cause
that yeah batman played a role in it but
for the most part it's just the man
hatter being the mad hatter and he was
committing intentional acts so
this is actually a really fun example of
the distinction between the two kinds of
cause i object to this witness she's
obviously trying to influence the judge
yeah that that seems improper
what makes you say that but of course
the writers know that they're they're
making that exact joke if there was no
batman there'd be no joker and i'd never
have met my puddin
thank you batman so that's not
damages that's a benefit wouldn't here
thinked on you in hopes of getting time
off
[Music]
he's got [ __ ] creep who witnesses
i mean the judge probably should find
her in contempt uh you know and sentence
her to
jail time for
assaulting him but you know and so it's
batman's fault you lead a life of crime
he should have let me bump off harvey
dent we'd all have been better off
wouldn't we have yeah you can't defend
your attempted murder by saying that
everyone would be better off if you
actually completed the murder itself
that's not an actual defense and it's
not
it's not a way of actually saying that
the person who stopped you from
committing murder
is the actual criminal that's uh that's
not a thing here
then it doesn't bother you when someone
let's say the judge here ruthlessly
plucks
a defenseless flower from the warm green
earth no but aren't the joker's flowers
canonically like they shoot acid they're
made of plastic it's kind of convenient
that there's a real flower in this
particular case
real convenient there one by one until
it's all gone
honey
i mean
it doesn't actually
change anything
i used to believe batman was responsible
for you people
but now i see nearly everyone here would
have ended up exactly the same batman or
not i mean so that's true but i think
we're still in the middle of the cross
examination here so you know
i know this happens on cb all the time
but you're not allowed to actually make
closing arguments when you're supposed
to be questioning people that's uh
that's sort of trial 101 oh the gimmicks
might be different but you'd all be out
there in some form or another bringing
misery to gotham the truth is you
created him and of course not for
nothing there's no bailiff here and so
the bailiff can't police the fact that
she's just walking around the entire
courtroom because you know you're not
allowed to actually enter the well
without permission from the judge i
guess even in arkham asylum maybe maybe
i don't know jury you've heard the
evidence
consider your verdict so again in real
life this is not a close case at all
batman is not responsible for the
actions of the supervillains he has
however committed all kinds of other
crimes uh not related to these super
villains but that's a that's a subject
for a different video in light of ms van
dorn's stirring defense we have no
choice but to find the defendant
not guilty
[Applause]
oh cool so this episode is a really
wonderful exploration of the difference
between actual cause and proximate cause
they should actually watch this in law
schools to talk about the difference
this is this is way more interesting
than being in a law school lecture
you've proven that batman didn't create
us that we in fact messed up our own
rotten lives
and as we are so rotten vile and
depraved we're going to waste you anyway
yeah so that's not in the federal
sentencing guidelines either
but
you knew that
okay oh hold on hold on
so
first of all why does a
a mental institution have
a
electric chair because this is not a
prison this is not a place where people
are sentenced to death there's no reason
that that should be there also whether
gotham is new york or chicago neither
new york or illinois has had a death
penalty for decades now yeah i know this
takes place and
i don't care neither new york or chicago
or new york city or chicago have the
actual death penalty so no facilities
whether they're actual prisons or not
should have an electric chair in them at
all
i see now there's a need for the things
you do
but i'm still going to work toward a
city that doesn't need batman
me too
okay fair enough so batman escapes and
the district attorney learns that
batman is helpful still batman is a
vigilante who is committing all kinds of
crimes so i'm not sure that this
particular daetant is actually good for
the city or not it depends on who you
ask so batman gets a happy ending from
the district attorney but will he get a
happy ending from me
phrasing okay so this episode pros and
cons first of all great exploration the
differences between actual and proximate
cause and that's about where the realism
ends what makes it unrealistic
completely unconstitutional jury
completely rigged from the start and a
premise that wouldn't even get passed a
motion to dismiss so all in all
unfortunately i'm gonna have to give
this episode a d minus for realism
though in a plus in terms of just being
fun to watch he always knew how to make
an exit
now batman is a guy who knows a thing or
two about comfortable underwear after
all he wears them on the outside now i
don't but i do wear mac weldon's
incredibly comfortable boxer briefs on
the inside see
back weldon is known for their insanely
comfortable boxer briefs including their
new stealth boxer briefs it's so
comfortable eyewear too
oh these are great for everything from
working out to hanging out and it feels
like nothing like you're not wearing a
second boxer brief and if you're
watching this channel you're an adult
and you probably deserve to have nice
box of reefs and i can tell you it makes
a world of difference and i also love
mack weldon's radius pants which are
halfway between slacks and joggers they
are also insanely comfortable they're
for the man who can wear sweatpants but
doesn't want to now if i'm not in court
or on a zoom call with a judge i'm often
wearing mac weldon they focus on smart
design and premium fabrics i order in
multiple sizes have them shipped to my
home because who has time to go clothes
shopping and then just return the ones
that don't fit right and keep the ones
that fit perfectly and with mac weldon's
loyalty program you can get a discount
free shipping and access to new products
it's automatic when you sign up in order
at macweldon.com legaleagle now if you
would like to try mack weldon legal
eagles like you will get twenty percent
off their first order just by going to
mcweldon.com league legal and using the
promo code legaleagle at checkout or
just click on the link that's on screen
right now so just click on that link to
get 20 off your first order then
remember to use that promo code
legaleagle plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel and while
you're at it click on this playlist for
all of my other reactions where i'll see
you in court